time now for morning rounds our look at
the medical news of the week according
to the American Cancer Society lung
cancer accounts for about fourteen
percent of all new cancer cases a new
study out this week published in the
Journal of Clinical Oncology examined
how certain types of vitamins might
raise your risk a major finding was that
men who have smoked cigarettes and taken
b6 and b12 supplements for 10 years or
more have a thirty to forty percent
higher risk of lung cancer those taking
the highest doses of the vitamins had
about double the risk for current
smokers the risk was even higher no
effect was seen among women here with
more is CBS News chief medical
correspondent dr. Jon LaPook and CBS
News contributor dr. Tara Narula Tara
give us some of the main findings of
this study for both the smokers and
non-smokers I think it's really
important that we're talking about this
because if you see the headline vitamins
causes cancer it can be very misleading
this was a specific population of
individuals essentially either former
current or recent smokers it was an
observational study which means it
doesn't prove cause and effect and it
essentially looked at the use of b6 b12
b9 and multi vitamins over a long period
of time in this population and they
didn't indeed find an association the
association was strongest in current
smokers who took very high doses of b6
and b12 over a 10-year period in that
group there was a three to four times
increased risk of the development of
lung cancer now they did not see this in
women they did not see it in the
multivitamins they did not see it in
folate the thinking is that it's
possible that because between these B
vitamins are involved in DNA cell growth
repair and maintenance that somehow by
tinkering with the amounts in a
population of smokers with male hormones
over a long period of time at these
higher doses you might either stimulate
the development of new cancers or
accelerate the development of cancers
that are already there John did the
authors give any idea why the vitamins
might have this kind of impact in men
versus women there's some speculation
all right there are differences in the
way enzymes work between between men and
women and these are important functions
in the way
that DNA is synthesized and repaired
there are hormonal differences as Tara
alluded to and then also there may be
differences between men and women in the
very susceptibility to lung cancer in
the first place
Tara it's no surprise a group
representing the supplement industry
says that these findings conflict with
previous research quote the numerous
benefits of V vitamins from food and
dietary supplements including supporting
cognition heart health and energy levels
are well established so what do we know
about the health benefits of vitamin B
so what we know is that for most
individuals in this country there really
is no good data to support the use of
supplements unless you are deficient now
there are some populations that are
deficient in B vitamins people who may
have celiac Crohn's disease or other
disorders there are strict vegetarians
in that population there may be benefit
but in general the bulk of the research
does not show any preventive benefits in
terms of for instance cancer and so
there may be this signal of harm we
don't know but certainly when you're
looking at the doses we're talking about
the recommended daily allowance for
example that you get in a regular
multivitamin is about one point three to
one point five milligrams of b6 about
two point four micrograms of b12 in this
study we were talking about greater than
twenty milligrams of these six greater
than 55 micrograms of b12 that's about
ten to twenty times the amount you're
gonna get in a regular multivitamin so
again very large doses note our next
topic deals with the potential link
between sleep and dementia a new study
in the journal Neurology looked at how
the two may relate the research looked
at 321 participants who were over the
age of 60 at the start they were
followed for an average of 12 years
there were 32 dementia cases observed
with 24 due to Alzheimer's disease Jon
did the study what did the studies show
exactly in this relationship between
sleep and dementia well we know with
sleep there are the different parts of
the cycle and it starts with kind of a
light sleep it goes to heavy sleep and
then you get REM rapid eye movement
that's where we dream and they found
that as the amount of REM went down the
risk of dementia went up that's scary
news for a lot of people and I think
we've all heard of REM but we don't
necessarily know what happens in the
different sleep cycles why is that one
so important yeah so for a long time the
thinking was that sleep is this very
passive inactive state where your body's
essentially
shutting down and then with the
development of the EEG in the 1930s we
realized that actually during periods of
time particularly during REM your brain
can actually be more awake than like
when you're awake and so when they
looked at the brainwaves they saw that
during REM sleep you essentially have
kind of small fast brainwaves as opposed
to non REM sleep where you have large
kind of slow brainwaves REM sleep is
characterized by vivid dreams as John
mentioned your muscles remain paralyzed
your breathing increases your heart rate
increases your blood pressure increases
as opposed to non REM sleep which again
is much more kind of quiet you cycle
through these stages throughout the
night about twenty to twenty-five
percent of your night is spent during
REM and we don't know why you cycle but
the theory one theory is that it may
help with memory consolidation which
could play into some of the issues of
dementia John is this study saying that
there is a definitive link between sleep
quality and dementia we don't know that
yet and we don't know if it's cause and
effect even if there is a link and one
interesting theory is that there's kind
of a garbage collecting function during
sleep that you have these toxins that
accumulate and then at night it sort of
gets cleaned out but people shouldn't
freak out I know there have been a lot
of discussion about that we're all kind
of sleep deprived of sleep even if it is
a cause and effect it would only be one
factor there are a lot of other factors
including just living a healthy
lifestyle so but it is an interesting
and compelling beginning of research
finally inspired by a heavenly site
people came together here on earth
earlier this week Americans
coast-to-coast got to see at least some
of the great American Eclipse a thrill
for folks of all ages and something that
hasn't happened nationwide for almost a
hundred years
dr. LaPook got the chance to experience
the Eclipse at totality on a visit to
Oregon with his family John how does
this event impact empathy and I mean I
guess could more events have a similar
effect well I think what was not
captured by all the pictures was the
spirituality of the event and my son
Noah called it collective wonder I mean
we know we live in a world that's very
troubled then there are a lot of
differences among us but we also live in
a world that's miraculous after this one
moment we were all looking up at the sky
at this spectacular event not a
difference among us and maybe one moment
could become two moments and maybe
collective wonder could become a more
important force in the universe
that's what I learned from my son Noah
during the Eclipse elective one great
phrase
you guys both had totality we didn't
here in New York but it was the same
thing seeing everybody on the rooftops
looking up it really was an amazing
moment
doctors Jon LaPook and Tara Narula thank
you very much it played a crucial role
in world war two but was destined not to
survive it up next we'll visit the just
discovered wreck of the USS Indianapolis
and hear from those who survived its
sinking an ordeal that even inspired a
character in the movie Jaws you're
watching CBS this morning Saturday